lightsabers in Star Wars are a dime a
dozen but these particular laser swords
tucked into the background of ahsoka's
ship may have caught your eye while
watching episode 3 of Ahsoka a few
eagle-eyed Star Wars fans may have
spotted a lightsaber collection that
would put General Grievous to shame
opens in the training room on Ahsoka
Tano Starship where she and Padawan
Sabine Wren enjoy a brief sparring match
in the background is an Armory packed
with a wide assortment of lightsabers
though oddly neither Ahsoka nor Sabine
ever mentions this collection plenty of
fans online are no doubt wondering who
these weapons belonged to before they
wound up on ahsoka's ship presumably a
few of them or possibly all of them were
constructed by huyang since the ancient
Android aided several generations of
padawans in lightsaber construction we
know the lightsabers at the top of the
collection are hu Yang's work since he
carries four identical Sabers during his
training session with Sabine each
sporting a distinctive Circle Cross
guard and emitting an abnormally thick
blade for practice while these
lightsabers are clearly for training
only it's worth noting they all bear a
striking resemblance to the lightsaber
of Star Wars Rebels staple Kane and
Jairus which also featured a unique
circle cross guard but emitted a blue
beam instead far more interesting than
the practice Sabers are the more
distinctive blades adorning the training
facilities back wall each has an
extremely unique design which implies
that they belonged to other Jedi before
they wound up in ahsoka's Armory while
none of these lightsabers immediately
jump out as belonging to any known Jedi
there are a few familiar characteristics
among them the top right saber and the
leftmost saber on the second row sport a
sleeve of black rings which is an iconic
design on Obi-Wan Kenobi's and Qui-Gon
jinn's weapons in The Phantom Menace the
middle right saber Bears a sleeve with
black blocky protrusions like the
lightsabers of Yoda and Mace Windu while
the bottom right saber draws comparisons
to Blades of Stacy tin and Darth Vader
both of which have large protruding
activation switches the most unique of
all these Sabers are the two on the top
row the top left lightsaber Sports a
thick black sleeve not unlike Vader's
though oddly it opens up halfway up the
hilt like a mouth from which the rest of
the blade emerges the top right weapon
is also strange with an enormous emitter
that juts out above the blade and
seemingly has a chunk cutout the overall
effect is a group of lightsabers that
looks slightly familiar but have not
been connected to any known Jedi at
least not yet unless Ahsoka or huyang go
out of their way to identify who
originally owned these lightsabers
viewers can only speculate on who they
might have belonged to before the show's
events if huyang did not create these
lightsabers the most likely option is
that they belonged to Jedi that escaped
the massacre of order 66. Ahsoka could
have encountered these survivors at any
point after the Clone Wars though if
this is the case it begs the question of
why she took their lightsabers for her
own more probable is that they were in
the possession of non-jedi who either
stole them or found them after a fallen
Jedi cast them aside next time try not
to lose it yes master this weapon is
your life in the event that huyang did
construct all these lightsabers they
were probably made in case Ahsoka took
on another Padawan if Ahsoka ever
planned to teach other Force wielders
the ways of the Jedi something she
almost agreed to do for grogu in the
Mandalorian it stands to reason those
New Jedi would need lightsabers if this
is the case it's somewhat unfortunate
that Ahsoka brought on Ren as an
apprentice as she already has a
lightsaber courtesy of Ezra Bridger
regardless Ahsoka and Company clearly
have a huge number of lightsabers at
their disposal and one has to wonder if
these extra blades will come in handy as
the Ahsoka story moves forward
foreign